that's not the plan
so you are you have black in you besides
yes yes okay because there was this uh
in the n-word and yeah and I really
don't like that I really hate it
actually now her grandfather's black it
was just I mean I think that's enough
but me personally I mean she raising
[__] but it's not even it's not even
just that it's just like if I'm 20 this
20 that 20 this I'm not full it's not
like I'm half this like I'm a little bit
of everything so it's like I've seen a
little bit of everything like I can't
always sit at the table with all the
black girls I can't always hit the table
all the Mexican girls because they look
at me this or they look at me that I'm
not Netflix
I've I've been bullied by which like
well yeah cause you where you grew up I
mean I want to put your business out
there but where you grew up is a badly
Latin Community right in the valley very
much yeah like in the San Fernando
Valley yeah so so did you go to high
school in the valley
or did you guys meet at the same school
or so I went to like five different high
schools of course you did I went to a
lot of different high schools in search
of like football you know so yeah
because I mean you would have played it
in Fayetteville right yeah so whichever
school had like
a position for me and they had they had
a little bit of recruitment coming in I
would [__] with them you know so I went
to
I went to belgia and Burbank was a
private school I went to Valencia High
School my freshman year for like two
months and like by Santa Clarita yeah
Santa Clara I went to Valencia High
School for two months left
went to Belgium for like a semester left
then I went to um Golden Valley I liked
the Golden Valley because it was more
diverse really diverse that's what she
that's where I met her it's really like
where's that at it's in Santa Clarita so
it's a lot of um
this is diverse yeah like all the others
get sent there yeah I almost bought a
house out there yeah so I went to Golden
Valley right then I went to I tried out
for Washington High School in the hood
not my hood but like just in the battery
uh what other school what was it uh
larva Bond I was packed I tried it for
nerd bomb for long for a little bit
then I end up going to our leader yeah
that was that the prom that you guys
were never going to go to the valley
program so I went to our leader she did
all those I went back to Golden Valley
like my senior year like I went to like
five different high schools every year
every semester I was at a different High
School like what how old were you when
you had your six-year-old
I was eight I had was just about to turn
18. so this was like senior year well I
had graduated and my birthday was later
that year so I graduated and that's
probably when like it happened when you
guys in the same grade or were you
younger I'm one year younger okay so
freshmen when you were pregnant was he
at no no playing football no no it's
like when he just came back okay because
he he left right came back and then he
was just because he was kind of just
ripping and running and then I really
wasn't on my [__] like what's ripping
and running mean
no we was just doing our [__] we was
getting it how we could